Ray EPS the most prominent and vocal
instigator of the riot at the capital
on January
6th has finally been prosecuted and
sentenced years after countless peaceful
demonstrators such as Midwestern
Granny's and smiling selfie takers were
locked in the clink some in solitary
confinement for months and even years on
end the guy who most clearly egged the
supposed insurrectionists on went
uncharged this strange fact LED some
people to conclude that EPS was actually
a plant working for the federal
government in fact many Trump supporters
suspected that EPS was a fed the moment
he started making his incendiary demands
before January 6th tomorrow we need to
go into the capital into the
[Applause]
capital peace f f
tomorrow I don't even like to say it cuz
I'll be arrested well let's not say we
need we need to go I'll say it all right
we need to go in shut the up Boomer to
the capital Bas fed
posting We need to go into the capital I
didn't see that coming okay monent Hill
is not speaking we are going to the
capital where our problems are it's that
direction
he spread the word all right okay but
one more thing so can we go up there no
when we go in we going to get arrested
if we go out there you don't need to get
shot arrest us
all pretty weird huh but years later he
was finally
charged and now he's been sentenced so
that probably should shut up the
right-wing conspiracy theorists right
Rays has been convicted and sentenced to
a year of
Probation and some community
service unlike all the far more peaceful
insurrectionists Ray EPS will face no
jail time no solitary confinement he
won't even be called a traitor by the
media in fact he will be praised this is
how the Associated Press is reporting on
eps's sentencing quote a man targeted by
right-wing conspiracy theories about the
US capital riot was sentenced on Tuesday
to a year of probation for joining the
January 6 2021 attack by a mob of fellow
Donald Trump
supporters joining joining is what he
was doing he basically led the damn
thing and now he's a victim earlier this
year after the security camera footage
was released contradicting the earlier
Narrative of a violent Insurrection here
is how the AP reported on that quote
handed some 41,000 hours of January 6th
security footage Fox news's Tucker
Carlson has launched an impassioned new
effort to explain away the deadly
Capital attack now however it is the AP
that is explaining away and even
excusing the actions of one of the main
guys who led the supposed
attack I was previously on the fence
about Ray apps being a
Fed kind of thought he was but I I was a
little bit on the fence the purpose of
the process secution it seems was to
prove to people that he was not a fed
and as with so many minations of the
Geniuses who run our government the
actual effect has been the
opposite if I didn't think that Ray EPS
was a Fed before I am now 100% convinced
that he is I'm Michael nolles this is
the Michael nolles
Show
[Music]
the Gen Z girl is complaining about
working there's something more going on
here people are either defending her or
they're just mocking her as a silly
little snowflake I think there's more
going on we'll get to that in a second
first though speaking of the feds not
sending their
best you remember when that air plane
just kind of like exploded the other day
an American airplane this was an Alaska
Airlines flight that was going from
Oregon to
California then they get to 16,000 ft
and part of the wall just blows off the
plane and they managed to land safely
but obviously was a very dangerous
situation so now the national
Transportation safety board is
explaining how that kind of third world
accident could happen in America America
now our systems group uh began looking
at all the aircraft systems they
documented the entire flight deck and
they asked about the auto pressurization
fail light that did illuminate in three
previous flights there was a decision by
Alaska Airlines
to um a restriction actually they put in
place they call it an eops restri rtion
that uh prevented that plane uh from
being flown to Hawaii over uh water so
that it could if some if some light did
illuminate it could return very quickly
to an
airport so they knew about
this what the NTSB is saying is Alaska
Airlines knew that there were major
mechanical problems with the plane so
much so that they feared that if they
flew the air plane over the Pacific
Ocean where there was nowhere nearby to
land uh the plane could go down and
everyone would die they knew that there
were pressurization problems they knew
that the side of the plane could blow
off so they said okay the thing we
should do here is not retire the plane
and get a new plane what we'll do is
we'll just fly it from Oregon to
California this happened multiple times
I said well you know look it'd be very
awkward if a light were to go off while
we were over the ocean what if half the
plane blew off I don't know wouldn't
that that seems like that's the real
fear here and that's what happened not a
whole half the plane but a major chunk
of one side of the plane blew off
someone's shirt was ripped off of him a
teddy bear flew out the window the air
masks came down everybody started
freaking out and they luckily thankfully
thank God managed to land the
plane
what what kind of incompetence is
required at Private Industry and at the
level of the federal government to allow
this many warning signs to go completely
unheeded things are breaking down if
you've ever traveled anywhere around the
world in Europe in certainly in third
world countries you'll notice that one
of the the big things that we take for
granted in America is just that things
kind of function for all the ideological
strife and all the battles and all the
policy preferences that we might have
and we might not get and blah blah blah
at least things kind of work the cops at
least few years ago would show up on
time at least uh until a few years ago
food supply systems worked just fine at
least till a few years ago there was
generally rule of law at least the
airplanes worked you know and the and
the the roads worked and things the
society just moved and we are in for a
very rude awakening because for decades
now we have issued basic competency
training
in favor of Highly
ideological so-called education systems
just indoctrination and a bunch of
liberal goblook and we have neglected
the basic functions that allow Society
to work expect more doors to blow off
more airplanes now speaking of Infamous
airplanes the Jeffrey Epstein Saga gets
even more
bizarre they start teasing around New
Year's Eve that there are new
Revelations are going to come out about
Jeffrey Epstein new documents to be
unsealed by the courts and I said don't
get your hopes up this is going to be a
big distraction and then I was proven
completely correct about that and all
the news that we got was just stuff we'
already heard oh yes Donald Trump knew
Jeffrey Epstein oh yes prince Andrew was
photographed with girls and Jeffrey
Epstein oh yes Bill Clinton likes young
ladies wow shocking stop the
presses the the new information that
came out at least semi- new information
was that one of Epstein's accusers
who said that she had first or at least
secondhand knowledge of prince
Andrew with these girls of Bill Clinton
of all the big high-profile
clients she said she had tapes that
Jeffrey Epstein recorded these people
that we already knew but she said she
had tapes she had access to the tapes
she'd seen them her friend recorded them
whatever she got a hold of
them but that turned out to be fake news
because she made that accusation in 2017
by 2019 she said oh no I made up the
story about having access to the tapes
that wasn't real I just did it to Spook
uh Jeffrey Epstein so that he wouldn't
come and try to kill me and I also did
that to bring more attention to the
Epstein story well now she's recanting
the recantation she said yesterday these
are videos that exist the people that
know they exist I'm sure are very
frightened of them being released
meaning the guys like prince
Andrew uh there were apparently hidden
cameras all over Epstein's Island she
said it's no secret that everything was
recorded multiple victims have come
forward confirming my account along with
others I have also seen recordings in
his office she said in the time that I
was with Epstein Gillan Maxwell among
others regularly enforced that if I ever
did come forward myself and my family
would be harmed she said she's willing
to testify in court that she has seen
CCTV footage allegedly recorded by
Epstein showing these high-profile
men doing naughty things with her
unnamed friend so now she's saying I
have seen this footage it exists I have
seen it I can testify about it she goes
on when my friend had sexual intercourse
with Clinton Prince Andrew and Richard
Branson sex tapes were in fact filmed on
each separate occasion by
Jeffrey uh thank God she managed to get
a hold of some footage of the filmed sex
tapes which clearly identify the faces
of Clinton Prince Andrew and Branson
having sexual intercourse with her but
she goes on to say frustratingly enough
Epstein was not seen in any of the
footage but he was clever like that okay
so this actually is new information we
already knew the tapes existed it would
appear that the FBI when they raided
Epstein's Place took the tapes because a
safe went missing and we we don't have
the tapes and that would be the the
evidence that you'd want to collect so
Epstein's not in it but all these
high-profile guys are okay now the next
question is where are the tapes and this
ties in with the point I made earlier I
I actually don't really care that much
I I really don't want to see Bill
Clinton doing anything naughty on a
videotape it's okay I liveed through the
90s I remember the stories I don't we
all know what happened I don't need to
see it I don't want to see Prince Andrew
or Richard Branson for that matter
either I don't really even care about
the the Epstein Client List being
unmasked I mean it's good it should be
unmasked the people should be brought to
Justice I think that would be great but
what is much more politically relevant
is who Jeffrey Epstein was working for
so the way this place into that is
someone has those tapes someone is
covering those tapes up whoever is in
possession of those tapes if they are a
law enforcement agency or an
intelligence agency is protecting the
clients of Jeffrey
Epstein we know that gain
Maxwell is the daughter of Robert
Maxwell who is a spy
for maybe three intelligence agencies
Israeli intelligence British
intelligence maybe even Russian
intelligence we know that from British
intelligence actually we know that
Jeffrey
Epstein was very likely connected to
American intelligence because of the
testimony of Alex aosta the US attorney
who prosecuted him in Florida and then
was up for labor secretary under
Trump the next question is where are the
tapes who is holding those
tapes which agency very likely is
holding those tapes why is the agency
holding those tapes what was that
agency's relationship with Jeffrey
Epstein
before he was arrested the first time
before he was arrested the second time
before he totally killed himself and
afterward even if they had no
relationship with Epstein beforehand it
seems unlikely but let's say they didn't
and they just found these tapes why are
they hiding them
now what is that all about now speaking
of homes when you want access to uh
financing to streamline the way that you
are making credit payments you got to
check out American financing right now
go to americanfinancing.net it's 2024
it's time to get our finances in order
there is some great news for homeowners
interest rates have dropped down to the
fives a lot lower than where they were
last year what was it last year in the
sevens 8% if you have been buried in
highin credit card debt now is the time
to Break Free with American financing
American financing and help you access
the cash in your home to pay off your
highin debt last year their salary based
mortgage Consultants helped customers
save an average of $854 a month that is
a great way to start the new year if you
start today you might be able to delay
two mortgage payments call American
financing today at
8665695076
6569 4711 or go to americanfinancing.net
nmls
82334 nmls Consumer access.org APR for
rates in the five start at 6.46% for
well-qualified borrowers call 8665 69
4711 for details about credit card costs
and terms speaking of matters of the
heart not sure that what was going on on
Epstein Island was exactly a matter of
the heart but I guess it's somewhat
related there's a study out breaking
study love really does change how the
brain works an amazing study just came
out of
Australia says that uh ROM romantic love
has a connection to the release of
oxytocin often called The Love hormone
and this helps to explain why we seem to
go all kooky when we fall in
love it is thought that romantic love
first emerged some 5 million years ago
after we split from our ancestors these
researchers conclude love can be a an
elevating an amazing but also a
traumatic experience wow really that's
really interesting find of the study uh
they they find out that when people fall
in love our brains react differently and
our romantic flame becomes the center of
our lives and this study sheds light on
on the mysterious mechanisms that that
underly that experience according to Dr
Phil Kavanaugh from the University of
cona uh he says that uh romantic love is
associated with changes in Behavior as
well as changes of perception and
emotion says we know the role that
oxytocin plays in R Mantic love because
we get waves of it circulating
throughout our nervous system and
bloodstream when we interact with loved
ones the way that loved ones take on
special importance is due to oxytocin
combining with dopamine that's another
chemical that our brain releases during
romantic love meaning that quote love
activates Pathways in the brain
associated with positive feelings you
can read more about this groundbreaking
study in Behavioral Sciences except it
would be a total waste of your time
because it doesn't tell anything new
about love and I mention it not just to
make fun of this study or these
researchers or anything but to make fun
of the scientific modern scientific
Endeavor
broadly modern science is supposed to
shed new light on all the mysteries of
the universe it's going to unlock all
the keys to all those Mysteries and yet
we didn't learn anything new there yeah
anyone who has ever had a crush on the
girl in math class in seventh grade
knows that love makes you feel different
and behave different and talk different
yeah we all know
that so many of these scientific studies
do not tell us anything new they don't
explain anything they just Code common
sense in scientific
jargon well you see our new
groundbreaking scientific study shows
that you get a rush of dopamine and
oxytocin when you see that pretty girl
that you
Love Oh you mean I go a little
Gaga okay can you tell me anything more
about it no not at all we don't know
anything about why that happens or how
that came to be or the purpose that it
might serve or but but listen we're very
scientific so stop talking about Elation
and
infatuation and love affairs and start
talking about oxytocin and dopamine
that's going to explain it does it
actually does the opposite oxytocin and
dopamine mean nothing to me I don't know
what that means
I know what love is I don't know what
those things
are you see this even in the gender
debate what is a woman the question that
uh fascinated the entire world for a
year maybe still it's fascinating the
world and not only the Liberals but even
the conservatives were giving all the
stupidest answers well a woman is
someone with two ex chromosomes I don't
know what ex chromosomes are that that
means nothing to me when I think hey
close your eyes think of a woman did you
think of 2x chromosomes no you
didn't sugar and spice and everything
nice goes a lot further to to describe a
woman than 2x chromosomes or a human
person with a uterus or
whatever the problem here is not that
the left attacks us for being
anti-scientific or uneducated or Rubes
or idiots or not curious or what
whatever I think conservatives are much
more Curious I think we're much more
intellectually engaged generally than
the leftists and the materialists and
the libs
are the problem here is that the whole
modern scientific Endeavor that comes
out after the enlightenment after the
Scientific Revolution which doesn't
expand our Horizons of perception it
Narrows them it tries to pretend that
everything in life is just material it's
just chemicals and stuff but that isn't
true we know that that isn't true we
know that there are things beyond the
physical Beyond matter we know that
there is form we know that there is
metaphysical reality we know that there
is a moral order we know that there's
mathematics I can't touch mathematics I
can't pull mathematics out of the air we
know mathematics exists we know morality
exists even if Reddit tier atheists want
to deny that we know it exists we know
that there's a a natural moral order
that we can all know everybody on Earth
using his reason we I think we know that
our reason is pretty reliable some
people deny that too they say oh it's
just a delusion or what we consider to
be our reason what we consider to be our
perception of objective reality is just
socially constructed but we don't behave
that way we all behave as though it's
objectively true and we we argue and we
debate and we have all sorts of policy
battles based on the assumption that
these things are true even the most
silly materialist lib will in moments of
weakness appeal to Human Rights and to
what's good and what's even what's
true the the takeaway here is is that
there is a lot more to knowledge than
modern scence there's a lot more to
science than what we call modern science
now speaking of the science and that
gender debate Ohio Governor Mike dwine
who is a republican
allegedly made waves uh last week when
he vetoed a bill that would ban the
sexual mutilation of
children and that would keep dudes out
of the women's locker room he vetoed it
he said' no we can't do that totally
squished on the easiest political issue
of our time well now he's trying to walk
that back he just signed a limited
executive order on Friday
Banning on children this is just one
week after vetoing the bill that would
have would have gone much further and
actually gotten the job done why why is
he doing this well he he's been
absolutely excoriated by every sensible
person the right the middle even
Centrist liberals
he was attacked by Donald Trump trump
said I'm done with this stiff this guy's
a complete Joker which he obviously is
so he tries to undo it with an executive
order an executive order is much weaker
than legislation that he could sign if
he's having regrets here then go back
have the legislature pass it again and
he should sign it he should he should
override his own veto if he if he's
realized that he was
wrong but if he's trying to find a
middle ground
on
[Music]
on certain issues you've got to be
clear Clarity is always charity and on
certain political issues there's no
middle ground Mike dwan wants a middle
ground he's going to upset everybody and
he's he's in in fact digging that hole
he started digging even deeper now
speaking of male sexual issues this is
the most perfect transition think I've
ever had in the entire history of the
Michael nlls show you got to check out
hymns right now go to hns.com
hyns is changing men's Healthcare by
providing access to Affordable and
discreet Sexual Health treatments all
from the comfort of your home hyms
provides access to clinically proven
generic Alternatives that are up to 95%
cheaper with options as low as $2 per
dose the process is simple 100% online
meaning you don't have to endure any
uncomfortable doctor's visits simply go
to hs.com
canw answer a series of questions on
their site one of their medical
providers will determine the right
treatment option for you if prescribed
your medication chips directly to you
for free in discreet packaging because
some guys are going to get a little
embarrassed about that you don't need to
worry about that anymore hims does not
require Insurance you will pay one low
price for your treatments online visits
ongoing shipments and provider messaging
hims has hundreds of thousands of
trusted subscribers so if Ed is getting
you down it's time to change that start
your free online visit today at
hims.com that is hs.com
KW for your personalized ed treatment
options that is hs.com
prescriptions require an online
consultation with a healthcare provider
who will determine if appropriate
restrictions apply see a website for
details and important safety information
subscription required price varies based
on product and subscription plan
speaking of young people a young Zoomer
girl has just broken down in tears in
her car on Tik Tok because she doesn't
like
working I cannot stand how the news has
has been dogging jenzy and calling them
lazy for not wanting to work an 9 to5
for the rest of their lives let me put
it in perspective for everybody who's a
little confused here okay I work 5 days
out of the week 40 hours a week okay I
do not make enough to live on my own I
would not make enough to pay rent water
electric and eat all by myself I would
not be capable of doing that 20 years
ago when you were getting started you
could live on your own 20 years ago when
you first started you were able to do
everything that I am now struggling to
do let me add another perspective here
you've been working for 20 years you
have 20 years of working experience
behind your belt you have 20 years of
experience in a career that has allowed
you to gain raises to get more money to
profit you in an economy that you
created you could sit here and you can
call Jen Z lazy all you want but I've
been working my tail end off just to
barely make it by and respectfully I
don't want to do that for the rest of my
life so the usual talking points
conservative cable news reaction to this
is listen to this crazy snowflake she
needs to learn how to work hard 9 to5
that's only eight hours of the day
that's not even that all that much work
you know I I worked 16 hours a day I
walked uphill both ways in the snow and
the sleep I worked in the coal mines
when I was eight years old and I worked
my way okay fair enough yeah it's true I
work I work more than eight hours a day
and well maybe I don't though
technically I do and if you just log the
hours that I'm working on something that
pertains to my professional life it's
way more than eight hours a day but in
another sense I really don't work at all
because I love everything I do and I'd
probably do it for free and so that's
great now it wasn't always like that
when I was in my early 20s I was working
plenty of jobs that I didn't really want
to do and I wasn't being paid that well
for it and I was so sure and over time
if you keep working at a career and
maybe you catch some lucky breaks here
or there then you know your your
professional life gets a little bit
happier but it doesn't for everybody
some people work a job that they hate
for their whole lives and they just do
it because that's their responsibility
and all of that is fair enough and we've
heard all of that commentary
before the part that no one's focusing
on is that part she says right at the
beginning of the video she says I'm
working eight hours a day I'm working 40
hours a week and I can't even
afford all of the things that I need to
live
alone why does she want to live
alone why do you want to live alone
lot of people do live alone some people
do it because they don't have any other
choice or they don't think they have any
other choice some people do it because
they think that they want to do it but
living alone is is not ideal that's not
really what you want doesn't this girl
want to get married man is a coupling
creature don't you want to get marriage
is great most people are called to
marriage not everyone is called to
marriage some people are called to
religious life let's say but when you
don't live alone when you're in
religious life you're not going to get
married but you're going to go live
maybe with a religious order you're
going to go live in a rectory with a
full community around you some people
are not called a marriage some people
are also not called a religious life
some people live a a single life for
whatever reason but often they'll have a
roommate or maybe they'll live with some
family member or at the very least they
will live within a community to be
around people man is not meant to live
alone modern liberal society says we're
supposed to be totally alone as
independent as you can possibly be
Independence good dependent bad do
whatever you want whenever you want to
do it good uh constrain yourselves to
the rules of society bad but that's just
wrong you're you are not supposed to be
completely 100% self-sufficient and go
live in the woods somewhere it's not how
Society is supposed to work this woman
is complaining about something that she
thinks she desires that is totally
unnatural and not conducive to her
flourishing I'm not saying there aren't
problems with the political econom and
I'm not saying there aren't ways to I
don't know have debates over wages or
but in the good old days families lived
together they were bigger families they
lived together for longer and then they
got married much much younger and then
they built new families and they they
built strong thriving communities and we
lived as Citizens and social creatures
now we don't and it creates all sorts of
problems yeah you're right there is
something really wrong with working
full-time and not being able to have
everything that you
need maybe we need different things than
modern society tells us that we
do now speaking of judgment coming it's
a little bit of a weak
transition Judge Judy has just made her
political endorsement for 2024 I know
you were all waiting baited breath drum
roll please Judge Judy is endorsing
Nikki
Haley
yes what' you think I didn't I didn't
really know I assumed she was a little
bit right-wing but not totally
right-wing I don't you know she's a New
Yorker and she's and actually it makes
perfect sense that she would endorse
someone like Nikki Haley why why is she
doing it she said I'm proud to endorse
Nikki Haley because she's whip smart has
executive credentials and was a superb
Governor I truly think she can restore
America and believe she is the future of
this great
nation there are a lot of people like
Judge Judy out there for everyone who
wrote off Nikki Haley early on because
she's more Centrist and
she is more inclined to compromise on
issues that are really near and dear to
conservatives so a lot of conservatives
don't really like Nikki Haley there are
a lot of people like Judge Judy out
there whose political views are maybe
not totally
coherent but they they're still kind of
popular you know these days if you run
in really plugged in in political
circles politics is getting a little
more polarized and extreme the
conservatives are becoming more
conservative the leftists are becoming
more
leftist gone or the days of the Bill
Clinton new Democrats gone or the days
of Tony Blair new labor gone are the
days of the social liberal fiscal
conservative which was a a mainstream
way to identify yourself especially in
yepy and urban circles I'm not sure it
ever had a ton of
cache ideologically throughout the rest
of the country but it was popular Bill
Clinton got elected for two to two terms
the bushes Bush one was socially liberal
and fiscally conservative he got elected
at least one time and Bush two was a
little more socially conservative still
he gets elected twice and that was a
that view which is deeply unsatisfying
to people who are really really plugged
into
politics I think remains fairly popular
still ever since Tony Blair that has
defined the politics of of the United
Kingdom even when the the right- Wingers
win it's usually on a fiscally
conservative socially liberal platform I
think a lot of people look at that today
they say that's P that kind of view has
led to so many of the problems that we
have today it it's led to all the
economic uh problems that the left
complains about uh the inequality of
wealth and uh the depression of wages
and the Outsourcing of jobs which that's
an issue that the right complains about
but it's also led to all the social
problems that the write complaints about
the breakdown of the family the
redefinition of the basic building block
of society all the weird sex stuff it's
so in in some ways this fiscally
conservative socially liberal thing it's
it's the worst of all all political
views and
yet electorally it still seems to have
some power and the 2024 election is
going to
be uh a a bell weather are we moving
into a new political era or does does
that view that really took shape in the
1990s is is that still a holdover does
that the really plugged in political
people the ones who are terminally
online they say there's no way that sort
of thing could work we'll find out were
was the radicalism of Barack Obama and
the the reactionary radicalism of Donald
Trump was that an aberration and now
we're returning back to regular old
clintonian Center left kind of politics
or was it a real break and there's new
political era Dawning we will see and
Judge Judy will be one of the markers to
see whether or not that is the case you
may have noticed that we here at the
daily wire are big fans of facts and
logic and
biology we know that there are only two
Sexes we're not afraid to say it that's
right come get me I'll say it darn it
that's how courageous I am but some of
our loyal customers pointed out a flaw
in our Jeremy's shop we only catered to
one sex well Jeremy's razor is all about
equal opportunity to shop at the woke
free economy that is why we now have
Jeremy's Racers for women because the
sugar and the spice and the everything
nice in life deserves the same quality
woke free blades as men plus we have a
line of personal care products for our
better halves including moisturizing
shaving cream lotion body wash and
deodorant ladies go over to Jeremy
rers.us who says maybe there was a giant
tablet buried under that synagogue and
Indiana Jones was trying to take a look
it could be the case you know I'll tell
you I have been dragged online a little
bit in the comments section on the on
the show on all over Twitter and for
suggesting that I am skeptical that the
Jews were committing human sacrifice and
trafficking babies and harvesting organs
in the little tunnel by the habad place
I have been dragged I've been called all
sorts of I've been called an idiot and a
Ru and I don't know I just it seems to
me I could be wrong I guess I've been
wrong on occasion before it seems to me
unlikely that the habad laiter rabbis
are are sacrificing babies and
trafficking children and committing
human sacrifice and stuff underneath
that little area of the synagogue it
could be it I'm not saying it can't be
but I don't really see any evidence for
it you know there's the piece of
evidence that keeps going around is they
say that that in the video where the
cops show up and they say clean up this
hole they people take a a stained
mattress out of the tunnel so I go back
to the tape and they don't though they
take it out of the wall the space
between the wall paneling and the closed
off part of the tunnel it's not in the
tunnel the tunnel isn't open there so I
don't know if you have
evidence that the habad necks are doing
human sacrifice in this tunnel from one
building they had to another building
that I think they used to have or was
closed down or whatever like a block
down um I'm I'm open to seeing it okay
I'm not I'm not the tunnel is weird I'm
not going to deny that the tunnel is
weird but without any good evidence of
that I don't know it would it seems to
me The Prudent and reasonable thing to a
on the side of Not Human Sacrifice I
don't know I could be wrong but that
seems reasonable to me now speaking of
complex political shifts
as actually pertains to the hebraic
people and uh their enemies over in the
Middle East uh some Pro Palestine
protesters uh a couple of days ago were
vandalizing US military US military
cemetery and blocking highways so you
might have seen the videos going all
around this free Palestine stuff
graffitiing at cemeteries and then and
then blocking all sorts of Highways and
there was a great video of a guy he's
pulling up and you got these Pro
Palestine people shutting down the
highway and this guy pulls up and he
screams at them and he says hey I got a
daughter in Brooklyn I want to get to
Brooklyn get out of my
[Music]
way you're destructing traffic idiots
you can't do that that's against the law
I'm about to start whing I'm about to
start throwing fist at y bro I'm not
going to run y over get away from my car
bro get away from my car don't tou it
bro get away from my car I have a
daughter in Brooklyn go
tou out way over over it pushes him over
they're still not really moving one of
them went down like a ton of bricks but
the other ones don't move and then he
just starts slowly driving his car he
has a lot of restraint this
guy slowly
driving but he's kind of like tapping
him a little bit and then he just goes
which is very admirable restraint and
the right thing to do absolutely you got
to go get to your daughter you you are
not going to let these wackos slow you
down or stop you from doing it entirely
the reason I bring it up
is the Israel Palestine conflict is not
the biggest issue for me I'm not saying
I don't care about it at all I do care
about it in a general way but it's not
very high up the list there are other
political priorities that I have I care
about other International conflicts too
I care about the Ukraine war to some
degree it's kind of low on my list I
care about the ngoro carab conflict
between Armenia the oldest Christian
nation in the world and the Muslims in
as ban I care about it it's it's still
not way at the top of my list and there
we're talking about the oldest Christian
Nation so I'm I'm inclined to care about
it even more but I can look at the way
that these issues are
coded political conflicts tend to be
coded left right in the case of the
Israel Palestine issue it doesn't map
perfectly onto US politics it's a
foreign conflict but in as much as it is
bleeding over into US Politics the
Palestine side is left
coded those people blocking traffic are
not conservatives they disagree with us
on everything those people who are
vandalizing military cemeteries they're
not right-wing they're not
conservatives there so it seems to me
just as a matter of practical Prejudice
I'm not going to go down into the weeds
of every single political issue I'm not
going to go write 150 page thesis on
every issue to really figure out what I
think about all especially International
conflicts that don't really involve me
all that much I'm just going to use
rules of thumb I'm going to use little
juristic and seems to me that in this
case all the most ardly Pro Palestine
people with the Palestine stuff in their
in their Twitter bios are
leftwing now I'm sure there there are
plenty of pro Palestine people in the
Middle East who would not call
themselves leftwing I'm just saying
that's how codes onto American politics
and so when it I'm not going to join the
pr liberate Palestine protest in America
because frankly the pro Palestine
protests in America aren't even really
about Israel and Palestine when when
some
purplehair shows up and says we need to
free Gaza you know it's obviously
ridiculous and the person would be
thrown off a rooftop in Gaza but they're
not really protesting anything about
Gaza or Israel they don't know anything
about it and they don't really care
they're protesting
American conservatives they're
protesting the white man they're
protesting the patriarchy they're
protesting George Washington and Thomas
Jefferson okay and they're they're using
the Israel Palestine conflict as a way
to express their anger probably at their
own fathers but but at all of the rest
of us so that that's the issue that's
that's really being debated here the the
the the Palestine Liberation protests in
America like around the world it
probably does involve a land conflict in
the East but in America it's not so much
about the Palestine as it is about the
Liberation and the ideology of
Liberation is very very bad and it's
very very leftist and it has to be
opposed
because they're going to be toppling
they are the same people who are
toppling statues of George Washington
who want to abolish the prisons who want
to let the criminals roam the country
who want to get rid of our borders who
want to upend everything that's the way
I think about I've said from the
beginning the American interest in the
Israel Palestine war is to contain the
war so that it doesn't expand throughout
the region or God forbid become a major
world war that drags Us in because I
have no interest in the US getting
particularly military involved in that
particularly militarily involved in that
uh but when it comes to blocking you
know roads in Brooklyn that's not what
we're dealing with we're dealing with
the same people that show up to the
antifa rallies the same people that
tried to blow me up at Pittsburgh the
same people that triy that shut down the
country that rioted over George Floyd
what George Floyd wasn't even over
George Floyd it was all just over the
same the same enemy that they perceive
themselves to have which is us which is
normal people speaking of racial and
ethnic conflict Joe Biden has has been a
race Hustler for a long time it's gotten
worse in recent years he launched his
2020 presidential campaign on a lie that
Donald Trump called neo-nazis very fine
people in Charlottesville is totally
fake uh now he's he's explaining he's
giving a damning example of that
systemic racism that he's been
fearmongering about for years years so a
home owned by today a home owned by a
black family on one side of a highway
built by the same Builder on the other
side of the highway and a white guy
living in it the white guy's home is
valued more than the black
guys no I know you know it but guess
what that's how you build generational
wealth now listen guy got standing there
on the on the side over on the hel said
make
come I I think the point if there was a
point in that said you got two homes in
two different parts of town one on one
side of the highway one on the other you
know the right side of the tracks and
the wrong side of the tracks and they're
both built by the same architect but one
is worth more money than the
other uh-huh you know they always say in
real estate they always say the three
most important words in real estate are
architect architect architect right is
that what they say no they say it's
location location location so he's
saying yeah this this one house in a
nice neighborhood is worth more money
than the house in the bad neighborhood
neighborhood and the bad neighborhood is
a bad neighborhood because for all sorts
of reasons maybe it's not as
geographically ideal and there's
probably a lot of crime going on and
maybe it's economically depressed and
the good neighborhood is nice and safe
you know and it's uh beautiful to look
at and it's it may be uh more accessible
to certain places but uh yeah that's
true has where's the systemic racism
where's the example of that don't I
don't quite see it as with many things
Joe Biden says I don't quite see see it
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it become a member
use code noes K has a check out for 2
months free on all annual
[Music]
plans